today Shannon and I are going to speak
about how math are used to model the
epidemic of cooking but we're just gonna
start with a little bit of background
about ourselves
oh I'm Sinead I'm originally from
Glasgow in Scotland and now I'm working
at company in rats in New York as a
postdoc unlike Keaney said my research
focuses on using mathematical models to
understand how our new systems respond
to virus infections and I'm Chloe and
I'm originally from Toulouse in the
southwest of France and I moved to New
York early last year and also pasa
Colombia in the same key machine and and
working on mathematical models for the
immune system as long so it's just some
information about me I've been working
in New York for two years now and
usually I love to travel so this is my
me my boyfriend on a trip to Scotland
last summer but since the I break
started me being sheltering at home with
our dog Dixie and you can probably tell
that she's not really a fan of posing
for photographs by her face here but she
is very happy that we're both working
from home now and can keep her company
all day and in my spare time I've
started taking an online drawing class
just to improve my art and I moved to
New York City early last year I've been
really enjoying exploring the city you
can see a picture of my good friend
Kalina and I in Greenpoint where you
have a pretty great view of the other
skyline and since the beginning of the
epidemic I've been staying with my
boyfriend working from from his place
I'm getting to know his cat lady and you
can see it's doing well because she's
taking selfie with me now and I'm also
cooking a lot and I'm trying to find the
best cheese recipe ever and this is one
of my experiment from a few weeks ago
but you can see here so before we get
started we just want to let you know
that our presentation will be a little
bit different from previous day Porky's
because most of the papers presented
before used reason that was based on
experimental data but we're going to
present another style of scientific
reasoning called mathematical and
hypothetical modeling
essentially what that means is that if
you want to understand a particular
process you can use mathematical models
to simplify and represent it and today
we're going to show how those simplified
models can be used to understand the
start as close to the outbreak and so
you may have noticed that his style of
scientific reasoning it has got a lot of
media attention recently as governments
and policy makers have been consulting
with scientists and using their
mathematical models to help plan
pandemic response efforts so you may be
familiar with terms like flatten the
curve modeling the impacts of social
distancing and the value of a quantity
called R naught and we'll be discussing
all of these things today as we go
through the paper so here is the paper
it's called the effect of control
strategies to reduce social mixing on
outcomes of the covert 19 academic in
Wuhan China a modeling study so it's
quite a complicated title but if you
focus on the phrase control strategies
to reduce social mixing that essentially
means the rules of social distancing and
so what the authors do is they use
mathematical modeling to explore what
would happen the stars called to
outbreak when you lift the rules of
social distancing and they use Wuhan in
China with a virus first emerged as a
case study and so you might be wondering
why would Han and an important point to
know is that this paper was published in
March and at that time one was still
very much a global focus of the outbreak
and social distancing rules had already
been established there and so learn what
might happen when you lift those rules
could help us understand how academics
will play out in other locations as well
and another thing we want to mention
about this paper is that it's already
been cited over 170 times which means
that over 170 other papers that have
been written just since March have
either mentioned or used the results in
this paper in some way and that's a huge
number in just two months and it really
shows how fast the pace of research is
moving in response to the pandemic
another cool thing we want to highlight
is that all of the authors are based in
London in the UK they have experience
model
infectious diseases around the world and
so some of the other settings that
they've worked on are Ebola in West
Africa dengue and Indonesia
Jiki Zika and Singapore and tuberculosis
in Cambodia and so this just goes to
show that you know mathematical modeling
isn't just used in the fight against our
school food but in the fight against
infectious diseases around the world
ocean I just showed you that this London
team has been working on modeling a
different number needs and actually one
of the first question you could ask us
is why do we use model which is a
legitimate question to ask
so basically when a disease spreads in
the population a lot of questions are
raised and in particular how fast and
why disease price and those questions
are really important and eventually by
knowing a little bit more about the
disease we can also determine how to
slow down the spread of the T V and
basically mathematical models can be
used to capture to send the transmission
process and study which interventions
can be used and can be helpful and
actually studying infectious disease is
not new and for example one of the
pioneer in this field was John Stone so
some of you may actually be familiar
with his name he's a famous character of
the Game of Thrones series but the real
Jon Snow was actually an English
physician in the 19th century and here
is the real Jon Snow and and he's known
for his work on a cholera outbreak that
was going on in London in 1854 and at
the moment people didn't know what the
Jesus was coming from there was no
knowledge about germs and microbes as we
know now and it was basically thought
that the disease was caused by the bad
quality of air but Jon Snow at the
moment studied the pattern of infections
in London neighborhoods and he
understood by studying those patterns
calera was transmitted by some pain by
an agent in continuity contaminated
water and so that led the government to
take actions including replacing the
pumps and that over improve the quality
of water people
had access to and I want to just quickly
mention some other pioneers who studied
infectious disease so here you've got
Anna Wessels Williams and she was
actually a New Yorker and she was one of
the frontline scientists working on
measures of fighting the panic of flu in
1918 and you may have heard about this
enemy because people have been speaking
a lot about it might be and here is
Fidel mondo and she worked in the
fifties on understanding the
transmission and the characteristics of
dengue in the Philippines dengue being a
tropical disease that's transmitted by
mosquitoes okay so now let's get back to
the paper and today we're going to focus
on two of the author's main objectives
subjective one was to use a model to
predict what would happen in wuhan if
and when social distancing rules are
lifted and then objected to was to
explore how transmission from children
affects the progression of the epidemic
and the reason that they included this
second objective is that when the work
was carried out observations had been
made that children seemed to be less
affected by the disease in adults but it
wasn't really clear where their children
were transmitting the disease as much as
adults which is still the case now and
so the authors wanted to see hide-a-key
and pipe the outbreak but Before we jump
into the paper there are a few key terms
that we want to go through that may be
unfamiliar but they're used a lot in the
field of Epidemiology and they'll become
important when we get into the details
of the paper and so some of the things
we'll go through are the latent and
infectious periods are not and re and
then also what the transmission rate is
and what a simulation is and so first
the latent infectious trees so if you
think about someone who's just been
infected with the virus it takes some
time for the virus to enter their cells
and grow in numbers and during that time
period although they're infected they're
not yet infectious and so they're not
yet capable of infecting someone else
and we call this time period the latent
period then after some time they'll
become infectious and at that point they
will be able to infect or transmit the
virus
someone else and so then we say that
we've entered the infectious period and
they're capable of transmission and then
finally after some point in time they'll
recover from the disease or in very
unfortunate circumstances will die from
the disease and at that point because
they're no longer infected and all
transmission has stopped we see that
we've entered the recovered period and
so another important term that we want
to go over is our not or the basic
reproduction number and it's still
definition is that it's the average
number of new cases caused by each
infectious person at the start of the
epidemic and it essentially measures the
potential for a disease to spread in a
population so if you imagine that you're
the first class and infected with a new
disease and are not is a number of new
people that you'll go on to infect and
also the number of new people that those
people are going to infect and so on and
so in the slide we showed an example of
R not equal to two so you start with one
infected person and then that infected
person goes on to infect two new people
and then each of those two people goes
on to infect two more new people which
leads to four people infected and so on
and so on and so in reality you may find
that some people only infect one person
and maybe others infects people but an
average we say that is two and from the
picture you can see how very quickly we
can build up having a lot of new people
being infected and so one important
question is how can we use our not at
the start of an outbreak to predict
whether the disease will successfully
spread in the population and actually
it's pretty simple because if each
infectious person in face less than one
new person on average then the number of
new cases will decrease in the disease
will fade out and so in other words if R
naught is less than one the disease
won't spread but if rcuts greater than
one like an example then the number of
new cases will continue to grow and so
the disease will spread and this is just
to give you an example of hosts that are
not for SARS called - compares to other
infectious diseases and so the value for
this people we're looking at today is
they use the value two
point five and you may have seen some
other values being used and that's
because there is some uncertainty around
the tree number up and this is partly
due to the fact that people use
different data to estimate these things
but if we think by the value of 2.5 we
can compare that to other diseases and
we can see that seasonal flu and Ebola
both have values that are less than 2.5
whereas smallpox and stars called 1
which was the virus that caused the SARS
epidemic in 2003 they both have
moderately higher amounts between 3 & 5
whereas measles has a much much higher
are not at 15 and it's worth just
pointing out here that are not doesn't
tell you anything about how severe the
diseases but just how well is friends
this is a 1 quantity that's very similar
to our lot which you may have also heard
of it recently is the effective
reproduction number or re or sometimes
it's also called RT and sometimes just
our unlike our not our t measures the
average number of new cases caused by
each infectious person but instead of
being used at the start of the outbreak
we use it once the outbreak has taken
off so if you remember our example of
our not equals to since it's at the
start of the outbreak no one has had the
disease yet and so everyone is at risk
of being infected but if you compare
that same example for our e we can see
that now on average each person is
infecting less new people and that's
because since the outbreak has taken off
now some people have already had the
disease and recovered and so at least in
the short term they can't be infected
again and so the value of our e is less
than the value of r-not because there
are less people available to infect once
the academic is taken off and so one
thing you may have noticed is that are
not is fixed at the starving it epidemic
and doesn't change whereas re you can
change over time as a number to prove
recovery changes and so re is also a
very important measure because we can
use it at any point in the outbreak to
determine to determine whether the
disease will continue to spread like we
did with our not at the start at the ED
break
and so if our E is less than one then
each infectious person will infect less
than one new person on average and so
the number of new cases will decrease
whereas art if ru is greater than one in
the number of new cases will continue to
I think we have that ok so here's here's
our question for the pull a question is
imagine you were the first person
infected by stars cool - or Ebola - how
many people would you transmit the virus
is it less than two between two and four
between four and six or more than six so
we'll give you a few moments just to
type in your answers okay that's grace I
think most people have voted now and it
seems like yeah most of you got the
answer right it's between two and four
because we saw that there are not four
stars called tunes 2.5 and for a bullet
it was too great okay so one last one
today that's also related to our knot is
a transmission mate and essentially for
each infectious person that measures how
many people that they will infect on
each day that they're infectious so for
example if I stay at home and I do I
don't come into contact with anyone
I mean I'm infectious but because I
haven't seen anyone I won't be able to
actually infect anyone but if I decide
to go out one day and I have contact
with five other people like in the
example and if their chance of infecting
somebody who I have contact
is one in five then overall end up
infecting five people and so you can see
that the transmission rate not only
depends on the number of contacts that
you have but also on the chance each of
those contacts results in transmission
of the disease and so as an example we
at the start of the epidemic we can link
the transmission rate who are not
because if I infected people on one
person each day that I'm infected
so my transmission rate is one and I end
up being infectious for two days then
overall on and say two people and so
that would correspond to a value of are
not equal to two so the first one we
want to go over is simulation and that
term relates to how we use models to
make predictions so for example if I
want to use a model to look at how a
disease will spread in a city like Wuhan
I need to know some of the value of the
key trends like transmission rate or not
that scheanette just introduced and
really often we don't know the real
value but we have an idea of the range
of those values so for example I may
know from other studies that are not is
somewhere between two and four
choosing values in this range so for
example here I choose or not equal to
and then I run the model and I look at
what happens so here for example I look
at the number of cases over time to see
how the outbreak progresses but as
scheanette just said around is a key
true
you is very likely to change the outcome
so here the number of cases so what I
can do after that is taking R not equal
to four instead of two and then I ran
the model again and I see how that
modifies the freshen of the outbreak and
so each time we run the model we call
that a simulation and then our nerd is
called the parameter because it's a
volume we can modify each time we run
the model so other important parameters
are actually the transmission rate
infectious period and the latent period
that were just explain you why she okay
so know that we went through all of the
key terms let's go back to the paper so
that's just a reminder of the key
objectives the first objective
happens when the social distancing rules
are lifted and then the second objective
is to explore how the transmission from
children can affect the production
repression of the epidemic
so we'll be speaking a lot about models
so let's have a look at what this math
model is and how it's built and
something I want to mention before I go
through is that the model that we
present is the one who's in the article
but it's a classical model that is used
by a lot of researchers to would of
different without infectious disease
transmission in populations and so it
would be the same principle for other
disease so that's basically the model
and what we do is basically we divide
the population into different groups and
the groups depend on the disease stages
of the people so the people in white
here are the susceptible which is
basically all of us last year regarding
could be 19 it means that we've never
seen disease and we can catch it then
we've got the people in pink and in red
and those people are infected by the
various virus the virus is in their body
in red here infectious which means that
they can transmit to the susceptible
people in white and infected people who
cannot transmit the virus the people in
pink hair or cold exposed and finally in
blue are the people who recovered for a
bit from the infection or and something
to see in some cases by from the
infection so know that we have our
groups you may wonder what I mean so
let's take a simple example so at the
moment it's very likely that myself I
mean a susceptible group in white and so
you can imagine that tomorrow for
example I go do laundry in the basement
of the building and I chat with my
neighbors but the issue in bird is
infectious and he doesn't know it and he
also had the very bad idea of not
wearing a mask when he go to the laundry
so by being in contact with him I catch
the
virus and I become infected without
being able to transmit the virus right
away so that means that I'm moving from
the susceptible Bell group to the
exposed group and that process of moving
from one group to another to the city
from the susceptible to exposed is
defined by the transmission rate which
as Gina explained is determining on
average how many people my neighbor will
transmit the virus each day and
unfortunately I'm part of those people
that day then I stay in this exposed
edge so I'm infected by the bar
I cannot transmit it yet and that amount
of time is defined by the latent period
so after that periods which is going to
last around lips like five days I'm
gonna become infectious and then I can
transmit the disease so when I am
infectious I can transmit the virus to
other susceptible persons if I don't
stay home for example
and in finally unable to transmit the
virus during the infectious period and
after that time which lasts roughly
seven days I'll hopefully recover so now
you know that the arrows represents how
and how fast people move from one group
to another one in the model and
basically what we do is the model is
making sure that everyone belongs to one
of the group and every day we look at
what has changed in the population so
today I'm in the susceptible group and
my neighbor is in the infectious group
and tomorrow the model which will
predict that I am in the exposed group
and so on every day and so what we are
interested in is how many new cases we
will have every day which is basically
how many people moved from the
susceptible to the exposed group every
day and then finally there's something
that we haven't mentioned yet but you
all probably know that not everyone
develops symptoms when they are infected
by the virus and so we can divide the
group of infectious people into two
additional step groups of people so we
have the people with symptoms and the
people without symptoms and for example
based on the first observations we think
that children's children will have less
in terms than adults and so they will
more likely be in that room than the
other one okay so the COI just went
through the models of the authors use
and now I'll go through how they
incorporate social distancing into that
model but first going back to the
transmission rate we said that it
depends on the number of contacts that
each person has and the chance that each
of those contacts actually results in a
new infection there's something that we
didn't mention is that the number of
contacts that person has can depend on
their age so for example if we think
about what happens during the day we
might expect that working adults will
mainly come into contact with some other
adults whereas children may come into
contact with lots of other children if
they go to school or nursery and the
elderly may come into contact with some
other adults and some other elderly
people for example if they live
partners of the same age are at the 11:8
care so these differences are actually
very important when we start to think
about the impact of different social
distancing measures for example if we
think about closing schools then that
will mainly reduce the number of
contacts among children whereas if we
introduce social distancing in the
workplace so-called workplace distancing
then that will reduce the number of
contacts mainly among adults and then if
we introduce the social distancing in
the community our general social
distancing such as closing public spaces
are stopping people visiting their
friends and family then that move just a
number of contacts among everyone but
here we shouldn't have it could impact
contacts of the elderly just as an
example and they made a point here is a
different social distancing measures
will reduce the number of contacts in
different age groups and as a result
will reduce the transmission rate in
those age groups and so incorporating
social distancing infant model is the
same as reducing the transmission rate
in each of these age groups and as Khoi
said that's just like reducing the
number of people who moved from that
susceptible group into those infected
groups okay so how does this all relate
to the paper well in the paper they
explore what would happen in four
different social distancing scenarios so
the first scenario in purple is if no
social distancing was in place so
essentially a daily life goes on as
normal
the second scenario in blue is if
schools were closed and workplace
distance seems introduced but only for a
month between January and February the
third scenario in orange is if general
social distancing was also introduced so
all three measures are in place from
January and then this goes on till March
and then scenario 4 in yellow is the
same as scenario 3 except instead of
ending in March it runs all the way
through to April and so there are a lot
details about these different smiles but
you don't really need to remember them
all the main thing to remember is it
scenario one is when there's no social
distancing and then as you move up from
one to four the measures get more
intense on are in place for longer
periods of time but once each of these
rules are listed life goes back to
normal
and so for objective one the authors
wanted to explore what would happen in
Wuhan when in each of these different
scenarios and so before we show you what
they found I just want to take you
through the axis of these figures of
this figure because there is quite a lot
going on so along the x axis we have the
time since the virus first emerged in
Wuhan and it starts in November last
year and it runs all the way through to
December this year because the authors
wanted to look at what could happen in
the coming months and then along the
y-axis we have the number of new cases
per day in thousands and so for example
a value of 60 would mean there were
60,000 new infections on that date and
then finally the colored vertical bars
represent the times when those different
social distancing scenarios were in
place so there is there's no purple bar
because there is no social distancing in
place in the first scenario and then as
you move from blue to orange to yellow
you can see that the scenarios were in
place till either February March or
April and so now we've got our bearings
we can look at what the model
simulations look like and again there is
quite a lot going on in this figure so
if we first just focus on those first
two cars Sariah one and purple was when
there was no such social distancing and
then two was when schools were closed
and there is workplace distancing but
only until February and you can see that
by adding and just a little bit of
social distancing we managed to reduce
the number of cases at the peak at the
outbreak and that's that day when you
have the highest number of cases and we
also managed to delay the peak a little
bit and so essentially that's what we
mean when we say flatten the curve but
we managed to reduce and delay the peak
of egg break now if we focus on the last
two curves so 903 was when general
social distancing was also added and and
this was in place to March and then
scenario 4 was the same except it was in
place I know you can see we make even
more progress towards delaying and
reducing that peak and so these stricter
social distancing measures improve our
ability to flatten the courage and as
I'm sure you know that this is important
because it gives governments in health
more time to prepare and it means the
way fewer patients for them to treat
when the egg breaks at its peak which
means there's less chance of hospital
systems being overwhelmed okay so now
let's look at the second objective of
the paper and let me walk through this
slide also so here the question is how
transmission from children affects the
outbreak and now what we're gonna do is
just focus on the best-case scenario
which is the fourth scenario in yellow
that she's not just presented I was able
to delay if you take the must and
substantially reduce the number of cases
at the peak and so in order to measure
and quantify the impact of taking this
strict social distancing measures on the
outbreak the author's look at how many
cases can be avoided until the end of
2020 by applying based strict social
distancing rules compared to the worst
case scenario where nothing would have
been done which is the way in purple the
first one and then since we have in
sentences on how infection children are
in each cross the author's I've learned
a different simulation to explore what
happens when children are as infectious
at adults and that's the graph on the
left or what happens when they are less
infectious which is the graph on the
right so now let's just focus on the
graft on the left so children are
assumed to be as infectious as adults
and the y axis here is the percentages
of cases avoiding avoided by using the
most intense social distancing measures
from 30 to nothing and the x-axis is
breaking this down among different age
groups in wuhan so you can see that the
biggest percentage of cases which is
sure and here is around 15 50 percent or
more and that was avoided in young
people and also the elderly so here and
this is particularly important for the
early because they are the one who are
the most at risk of severe disease so
what this graph show is that by
introducing strict social distancing
mothers around half of the case we could
have expected by new nothing we're
avoiding in
population by doing the strict social
distancing goals and that's really great
and then if you look at the graph on the
right the author's assume children or
less infectious like adults and you can
see that these percentages of avoided
cases jumps from around 50% to 80% and
that's a big difference and that shows
that it's really important to understand
how much children contribute to this
threat of disease okay so now that we've
gone over the main findings from the
paper we can go back to these two
objectives and see how the authors
answered them so for the first objective
they wanted to use a model to predict
what would happen in wuhan if and when
social distancing rules were lifted on
what they found from the first figure we
discussed is that social distancing
helped flatten their courage and so at
this point you could rightly tell us
that you would have predicted this from
the beginning but where the models
really help is by putting numbers behind
this idea so it's important to know for
example how many cases we might expect
each day and by how much time we might
delay the peak so that hospitals and
governments can plan accordingly and
where the model also helps us is to
compare different scenarios and to put a
number on how much we might gain if we
use those stricter social distancing
measures and the second objective they
aim at exploring how transmission from
children affects the outbreak and what
they found from that second graph I
showed you is that if children are less
infectious than adults we can avoid even
more cases with those social dissenting
roles and again the model helps putting
numbers behind this concept and there's
still uncertainty actually about how
children are affected by the disease and
so this study highlight that we need to
do more research bother so one thing to
keep in mind is that the study was made
in Wuhan and the social mixing in new
Han may be different from other cities
like New York for example and so the
result was the same type of model in New
York will be different another point is
that
the study was conducted in March when
social distancing rooms were still in
place in Wuhan and now we know that
those holes have been lifted and so the
situation in new Honda has changed it
and if the authors want to incorporate
these changes they would need to gather
more data and update the model to
reflect the more recent circumstances so
keeping those two points in mind I just
want to quickly show you how the model
can be applied in other countries and
here what you can see is some
researchers from Columbia University who
are projecting the number of new
infections in New York City and they
actually regularly update the
protections using the collected data so
here for example I took what they did on
May 3rd so they they projected what
would happen 8 weeks after May 3rd by
using data that was collected before so
the blue part correspond to the data and
it's actually the same in the two
graphics what changes is the scale of
the y-axis so here you see this 30,000
is here will in this graph it's here
different scale but it's actually the
same the same data it's the same graph
the one in blue and then the yellow part
which is on the right of this dashed
line here and here a correspond to the
projection under the worst case on the
left meaning that all of the
restrictions are lifted in New York and
if we keep the restrictions as they are
at the moment so on the right and then
these two yellow lines here in dashed an
inclined line they just correspond to
different simulations that the authors
made but are based on different
hypotheses on the aspects of the
transmission of the virus that we don't
fully know so they just took different
branches as I explained at the beginning
then something else that we could do
with this type of model is studying
other type of interventions in addition
to the social distancing models so for
example if a vaccine become available we
can look at how the progression of the
outbreak is modified by introducing the
vaccine in the population using the same
type of model so basically what we did
at the beginning of the epidemic is
looking at how the disease will spread
population that is completely
susceptible and that's that type of
population here on the left and now what
we're looking at is what happens when
the transmission is in a more original
population so here what's happening now
where we have people who are still
infectious people recovered people who
are also still susceptible we can also
look at how the prediction of the
disease will be modified and hopefully
controlled by vaccinating a certain
amount of the population here in yellow
and we assume that those people who are
vaccinated they're not at risk of
catching the disease if the vaccine is
efficient enough and in something
finally about a Shannon 1:22 highlights
is that the models depend on the
accuracy of the data so you may have
heard at the beginning the models were
not good but there was not enough data
to make really great predictions and
which time we can refine estimation and
the predictions that we do with the
model by gathering more data on the
epidemic so now Lord we just wanted to
provide some additional resource where
you can look at up-to-date models and
see how they're using real-time outbreak
for testing so for example the first
tool here is an interactive tool that is
created by the authors and also other
scientists they collaborate with and you
can actually modify some parameters and
explore by yourself impact of different
social distancing measures on the
outbreak in different countries and the
second link it's actually the CDC
website or you will have results and
prediction from different models from
different genes and something we want to
compute with is that it's really
important to look at the results from
different models based on different
assumptions different data because
public health decisions are not taken
only based on the results of one model
but they're more based on the
combination of results from different
studies with different models